uh you know very wildly ambitious by the
uk
when we did it but you're now seeing
country after country
across the world uh coming into line uh
with global britain
thank you prime minister in the past few
weeks we've had the argument about the
new coal mine in cumbria
the transport secretary wants to make it
cheaper to fly within the uk
the green homes grant has been cut by a
billion pounds and presumably in cutting
our aid budget but also cutting climate
aid
do you think other countries will listen
to us when we ask them to be better on
climate action
yes because the the uk's thanks very
much but the uk's
uh first of all the uk's ndc 68
reductions on uh on 1990 levels is a
huge
uh commitment uh people can see uh how
big that is how determined we are
they also know that we have a an
incredible record of
of doing it you know the uk has uh has
already
uh delivered uh very considerable cuts
in uh
in co2 uh just in our uh you know in
maybe in my political lifetimes longer
than yours uh but just in my political
lifetime
uh we've done a colossal amount to
decarbonize
uh our our country i think when i was uh
in in 1970 when i was six years old i
think
i think and i died i doubt you're even
born uh
we we we were we were i think 70
90 of our emissions of our energy came
from
uh coal that's now down to much less
than uh
one percent right so so thank you thank
you i'm afraid i'm limited on time so
i'm sorry back to the 1970s i need to
move on um
it's been reported that you personally
breaked the deal for the uk to spend 400
million pounds buying the satellite
company
one web and that the chancellor
personally have to sign the check are
both of those reported
uh facts correct well uh i i
certainly the government uh was involved
at all levels in uh in in
in doing that in doing the in in doing
uh
the the deal i don't think i should
comment exactly on the
uh you know who did who did what but it
was it was
a uh i think that the ambition for the
uk
uh to have a presence in uh in space and
in the
the low earth orbit uh market is a a
notable one and
an important one uh i think for too long
the uk has been left behind
in the in the space race this is an area
of
colossal uh commercial importance and we
need to be there
to cut in i just wanted to know whether
you and the chancellor were personally
involved in breaking that deal
but could i just ask which budget line
in government did the 400 million pounds
come from
well uh the the uh
commitment as as you are as you all
know is is one that the whole of
government has made but if you're asking
which department
is responsible for uh for space
strategy then the responsibility lies
with the secretary of state for
uh for bays uh that's so that's quasi
quater
well thank you for that prime minister
and lastly and i understand that david
cameron contacted one of your special
advisers in number 10
to try and secure public funds for green
sill is that correct
uh that's news to me but um
you know any any such any such
uh contacts or or whatever
of course will be uh registered in the
proper way
i guess it might as i just say that in
response to my question about whether
you personally brokered the one web deal
whether the chancellor personally signed
the check and whether mr cameron
was having private conversations with
your special advisers you've not
provided an answer to any of those
questions and from a parliamentary
parliamentary scrutiny and oversight
great great great respect great respect
to you i don't wish in any way to
disagree with what you just said but um
on the on your
certainly on your point about uh contact
between
uh david uh cameron a former prime
minister in
my office or anybody in my office i
simply have no knowledge of that i
i i i that's that's news to me is what i
uh is what i said to you and on the the
deal with
uh with one web that was a deal
obviously done by by the government
thank you so i'm afraid we've run out of
time but i've enjoyed our time together
thank you back to you
unless the public accounts committee
wants to comment on that i'll move
straight on
um tobias elwood thank you very much
jaren thank you
uh prime minister i very much welcome
the integrated review publication
spelling out britain's vision and the
growing threats that we face
but just parking aside how we might
respond
prime minister would you agree with this
threat picture as drawn up from the
integrated review
the security environment is
deteriorating democracy and pluralism
will continue to decline
with strains on our international
institutions maritime tensions will
increase
china's assertiveness will not diminish
russia will continue to be a threat to
european security
threats of terrorism remain and new
domains of space and cyber
pose significant challenges and climate
change will progressively impact on
global few
food and water security so do you agree
with that summary
simple yes or no please that sounds very
sensible to me
well as we concur on that during the
cold war defence spending was at four
percent
gdp today's threats are indeed more
complex and more dangerous
yet we remain on a peacetime defense
budget of just 2.2
now we absolutely welcome the force
structure shake-up the investment in
sf lethality cyberspace resilience is
also welcomed
but it's coming at a huge price with
sweeping cuts to our conventional
defense posture exposing us to the very
threat that you and i both agree
are there is it not time to move britain
to a conflict footing
and raise defense spending to at least
three percent not just to defend our
interests
but to play a leadership role to counter
growing global instability
uh well uh tobias i have a highly regard
for your
uh expertise in this area and you and i
have discussed these questions many
times
uh and uh i know that you care
passionately about
uh this subject i i'm just wish to to be
clear the 2.2 percent isn't is an
increase it's it's not that we're
remaining at 2.2 percent we've gone up
uh to 2.2 percent as a result of the
biggest investment in
our armed forces uh in defense since the
end of the cold war 24 billion pound
investment and it is a full spectrum uh
investment it's it
it covers everything uh from cyber uh
to uh modernizing and protecting our
tanks
uh to enabling us to go ahead with the
future combat uh air system
uh that i think will be essential for
defending uh our skies
in the future and enabling us to protect
project uh for support the uk
uh is one of the few countries in the
world able to project force
uh at eight thousand uh miles or more
and this uh defense
uh integrated defense security and
foreign policy review allows us to
continue
to do just that thank you for that but
there are some
uh concerns i have the ranger brigade is
very much welcome but we're cutting our
marines
to just 400 the tempest you mentioned
also welcomed
but in order to pay for that in the
future we're having to clunk back on the
f-35s
and indeed our typhoons and our special
forces are going to lose their c-130
aircraft i'll be very grateful if you
could look at these details
but i am concerned of the wider picture
that we're not gauging ourselves up for
what's coming over
uh the hill it does feel a little bit
like there's competition
in our time and we are in denial as to
the scale of threats that we face
could i move on to another subject which
is to do with the office
of veterans affairs news today has come
out that there will be a 40
cut uh in the support here with a
reduction of its budget from
5 million to 3 million pounds i know
you're passionate about supporting our
armed forces
and the veterans as well we've come a
long way in providing that support
could i ask you to revisit this decision
uh
there's no decision thanks very much
tobias there's no decision that's been
taken about
the office of veterans of affairs and uh
the
spending on on veterans is after all uh
not primarily through that
through that office although uh johnny
mercer and his team do
an outstanding job uh we spend
up to 18 million pounds through the nhs
on
uh on specific mental health services
that are targeted
at veterans 10 million pounds to support
uh veterans
mental mental health charities uh we
have uh national
insurance uh rebates for those that uh
obviously subsidize for those that hire
uh veterans as well as uh as as
cut price transport of free transport
for uh for veterans
on public transport something that i
remember actually pioneering
when i was mayor of london and i'm very
proud that we've taken that
into government as well thank you
my final question is to deal with where
we might be um putting troops in
uh at the most earliest occasion and
that is in uh yemen
the ceasefire has been put forward by
saudi arabia a possible
solution political solution could be
secured we are the u.n security council
penholder
you and i worked on this subject for
some time would we be willing to provide
troops
if are requested for a un stabilization
force
we have indeed worked on it uh tobias
and i remember some of your
uh very creative uh plans that
that you uh suggested to me for instance
for a mission to
to to to consolidate hodeido and other
uh other projects uh vividly that we
discussed and
i know how much you care about the peace
and the security of
of yemen um uh we of course back the
uh the un-led approach that's been led
by martin uh griffiths as
as we both know i do believe that's the
best way forward it's encouraging uh
that there is a
a ceasefire now
between the uh the saudi forces and the
uh and the houthis we must hope that
that leads to
uh to serious political progress i think
that
uh it was not realistic um
to simply to say that the houthis could
not be
uh negotiated with or talked to uh in
any way that's that i don't think that
was going to work if you remember that
was a
previous approach i think we now do have
an opportunity to to go further uh let
there has been no specific request or
suggestion for uk
uh engagement but it's certainly
something that uh
we would be prepared uh to look at if
the conditions were right but i've got
to stress
before uh everybody on the committee
pricks up there is uh that you know
yemen uh the conditions would really
have to be uh very different from what
they are now
uh for us to go ahead with with boots on
the ground
thank you sir thank you prime minister
can i just interject one
point the decision and the integrated
review to
raise the cap on the number of warheads
came as something as a of a surprise uh
continuous at sea deterrence has always
been a bipartisan policy based upon
quite a broad consensus of course there
are dissenters uh
but it has been a bipartisan policy what
measures are the government going to
take to build the same kind of consensus
around this more controversial decision
about raising the cap on the number of
warheads
thanks very much bernard saverle i think
that you you obviously
personally have a great deal of
expertise in this uh in this field
and i i you know you're you're
absolutely right to raise it i
but it's it's it's crucial to stress
that uh the
uh the the number in question that's in
the integrated
review is a a ceiling uh it's not a it's
not a target
uh we remain as a as a government
committed to the minimum credible
uh deterrent and it's very important for
everybody
uh to understand that as well well i
hope there will be
open discussion uh as far as we can be
open
across the party divide yes and i think
that uh it certainly ought to be
possible on privy council terms
uh for members of this committee to
receive a briefing about
uh the nature of the of the decisions
thank you
moving on now to sarah champion thank
you chair
prime minister on monday you committed
to spending 188 billion
on defence over the coming four years
which is an increase of 14
so i'm curious how is there enough money
in the public purse to increase defense
spending
but not enough to maintain the uk's
legal commitment to spend 0.7 of gni on
aid
sarah thank you and you you asked me the
same sorts of questions
uh last time quite properly uh because i
think
uh you certainly care about this issue
greatly and so do i
uh i think that it would be a great a
donor
has been one of the the most important
features of
of our country of global britain over
the last few years but i just want to
try to reassure you
uh that we still are and uh 10 billion
pounds
in a year which is what uh we're giving
uh this year in uk taxpayers money
uh is is is a huge sum uh we remain
uh one of the biggest if not the single
biggest uh donor
european donor for instance to yemen
which uh tobias was
uh just raising and uh
of times the the you ask you know how
can we find the uh
the the cash for this and the the answer
is that times are very tight
we've had to spend 407 billion pounds
uh supporting our public services and
our economy
uh through covid and i i think people do
understand that these are
the exceptional circumstances that are
that are
uh foretold in the 2015 act and that it
is uh reasonable for us to to deviate
uh from that act under these extreme
under these extreme circumstances
thank you prime minister in the
integrated review you argue that
absolute poverty
is set to be eliminated in asia and
latin america
by the 2030s but by 2045 85
of the poorest billion will live in
africa you map out the projections of
global population
growth intersecting with climate change
poverty
conflict instability all being at their
greatest in sub-saharan africa
so given this stark backdrop why have
you decided to so sharply cut
development funding in africa
well uh thanks sarah
we haven't we still we're still uh one
of the biggest aid donors
uh in africa in the world and we will
continue
uh to be so uh we contribute for
instance
on uh to look at the immediate concerns
of
uh of the planet and of the african
continent uh we're one of the biggest
donors to
uh to to kovacs i think we've given 548
million pounds to the global vaccine
uh alliance i think uh 1.6 billion to
uh to gabby and
much of that funding uh goes to
distributing
vaccines to to the poorest and neediest
particularly on the african continent
thank you and prime minister i know that
girls education seems to be your
personal development priority
and fcdo has said that it will place
gender equality at the heart
of uk's odor work but you are cutting
funding to the international planned
parenthood foundation
which will lead to 7.5 million
unintended pregnancies
27 million unsafe abortions and 22
000 maternal deaths according to the
director general you're also cutting by
60
an international rescue committee family
planning programme in sierra leone for
adolescence girls
a country where one in 17 die in
childbirth
and you've cut another r-r-r-i-r-c
project in lebanon that would have
provided vital gender-based violence and
child protection services to 107 000
women and girls
and these are just the examples that we
know of how does that feel prime
minister when your ambition and the
reality is so starkly apart
i don't want to it's like
no prime minister no nobody who cares
about any of these
issues could conceivably want to make
these
uh changes and these these cuts now i'm
simply asking
you and people watching to understand
the particular difficulties that we face
right now our determination uh to get
back
uh to 0.7 when the fiscal position
allows uh but i think people will will
also understand our earnestness in our
series we i want to see another 40
million
girls into education uh by 2025. that's
that ambition
uh is still there we have the funding uh
for that we think we can
we can do that our campaign is for 12
years of uh
although you've mentioned some things
that we allow we sadly can't do
there are plenty of things that we're
going to continue to do and our campaign
is for
for 12 years of quality education for
every girl in the world and
uh together with uhuru kenyatta later
this year uh we'll be leading the girls
education summit
to try to uh to to promote that cause
and
uh right it's not it's it's something
we're spending
a great deal of money on it but it's
also about talking the issue up
hello prime minister does that mean that
you're there for ring fencing all of the
money around girls education and
preventing violence against women and
girls
uh it's a it's a priority of the of the
government and
the program will continue uh to the best
of our abilities and
our target remains unchanged we want
another 40 million
girls around the world to receive a
quality education
by 2025 so 40 million that wouldn't
otherwise without british intervention
get that education they need thank you
prime minister and finally
my committee is grateful for the support
that you gave to keep us
um but sadly your officials appear less
pleased as they're making it extremely
difficult for
philip barton to appear before us on the
13th of april
to discuss the changes in the alien
budget so can i ask you to intervene and
make him come in front of us please i
have intervened
he hasn't had intervene philip barton
will appear but i don't think he was
to be absolutely clear philip is a
wonderful man i don't believe he would
have been remotely reluctant to come but
he but he's coming well
thank you for that because he's the
accounting officer i understand for the
very large
a budget can i just raise a point about
the
science component of the aid budget
you've got a letter from the from greg
clark may not have this in your briefing
because the letter only went yesterday
but it points out that the um
the government's announced that the base
oda allocation
to uk research in innovation has reduced
significantly
as as part of the cuts in the budget
because we're now
taking horizon out of the out of the
science budget
can can you address that too that um
it's not in our intention to have a dip
in science
funding but just because we've signed up
to the horizon
program the horizon program was always
horizon
uh bernard as you know is a is a
wonderful
pan-european uh project
that is extremely costly uh and
uh the the way it operates at the moment
is that the uk spends a lot up front
uh and doesn't get much back for a while
and so uh
we're looking at that but in the context
of a a
a huge increase in uh investment in
science
in r d general there's never been
anything like it under any previous
government the particular concern is
the dip in funding creates discontinuity
in existing funding programs which would
be most unfortunate
i'm aware of that and i i've discussed
it with uh
uh with the chance with patrick balance
and others and we want to make sure that
scientists don't
uh have that um discontinuity that you
talk about
i'm most grateful angus brenda mcneil on
trade please
thank you uh very much um this section
as we know is the uk's
uh place in the world and they're just
specifically on the case place in the
world without a trade like a topical
linked prime minister
this weekend the clocks go forward to
british summer time and many people of
course have been looking forward to the
less dark evenings will this happen next
year prime minister the eu are not going
to do this apparently
and according to the house of commons
library the uk has said no times if a
clock changes in 2022.
so can you tell us uh will uh the uk be
copying the eu for opting for longer
darker summer nights or will you be
maintaining
a british summer time which would have
the added benefit of course of putting
their businesses on the same time zone
as those in europe if you do
uh well i guess it's an extremely good
question uh the
the the road map that we've set out for
uh going uh
taking our country on the path of
freedom as you know goes so far to
june the 21st i i we haven't looked uh
forward to
uh exactly what's going to be happening
uh next spring in terms of the
uh of the clocks but i'm happy to take
that one away
so you you could be the prime minister
who kills british summertime
is this important i'm gonna i i i will
have a look at the suggestion
uh that you made but it seems uh it
seems unlikely to me
okay uh moving on a little bit uh and
looking at the world and
democracy of course and respect and
democracy in on the ballot box
you know it's under threat in many
places and china russia and
places like bella used to play fast and
loose with the relationship with the
ballot box
i think it's important that we assert
our commitment to democracy and the
support
for the outcomes of the ballot box now i
know you're not in favor
at the moment of our referendum scottish
independence i'm not asking about that
i'm asking about but if the scottish
people or indeed the welsh people given
the
way polls are good they were to say at
the ballot box that they wanted
independence would you respect the
ballot box
and that decision if it were to come
about well
yes i i i'm glad you talk about
respecting the the ballot box because
there was as you as you as you recollect
a voter on the
uh on scottish uh uh separation on the
break-up of
the breakup and
i'm i'm very keen to respect that vote
but if the people vote any future
because you said that the
general election of 2019 was a once in a
lifetime general election and i
hope that doesn't mean you're you're
thinking that's the end of democracy in
the uk
i'm talking about the future
unfortunately i'm sure there will be
more general elections in the uk
but as long as it continues to exist in
its current form but if the scottish
people aren't
the worst people were to vote for
independence premises remember people
with china and russia and belarus are
watching you do you respect what the
people would say
at the ballot box well um i guess i
don't think even my
uh my my worst enemies or biggest
detractors would say that i'd
uh at any stage uh promise to abolish
general elections or
uh
to get rid of them uh so uh and there's
a clear difference between
uh the two things uh when you ask people
to vote on a highly
uh controversial and divisive uh issue
uh an issue that
breaks up family family relationships
that
is extremely toxic and toxic and
divisive
and you tell them that this is going to
happen only once in a generation
i think you should stick to it well i
think it's toxic
and divisive it's obstructing democracy
and i hope you would do that purpose and
i hope you would respect
democracy and not quite fast and loose
as we've seen in china and
russia and belarus in such places uh
i'll give you one more chance
do you respect the battle i i greatly
respect the ballot box tonight but
what i would will say about a another
uh referendum the independence
separation
continually campaign for i i think it uh
striking and in opposite that
and now when we're trying to come
together to come through a pandemic
uh to build that better together that
in instead of talking about any other
aspect of uh of global britain
uh and all the things that we do
together
our armed forces our security services
uh
our scientists working together around
the world which is one of the most
moving and extraordinary things
uh all we hear about is breaking up
the prime minister order the prime
minister well i've i've finished my
answers
thank you thank you very much and moving
on to
cptpp and the pacific the
comprehensive and progressive
trans-pacific partnership
at the uk it's interested in um do we
have any figures
on the gdp game so far the uk has
has left the european union and it's got
enough a lot of paperwork so much so
that my fine oysters
this week were saying it was 500 pounds
x downloaded 38 pages
it's a 4.9 damage to gdp event so far
there's been no three deal signed
that gains any of this loss to gdp
any idea what the gdp gain might be from
cp
the overall benefits of trade deals uh
uh are well attested and uh the
number and uh the uh ambition of this
country is to
uh is to continue to secure them we've
done uh
about um uh
60 more than 60 trade deals already
and uh the countries that we've secured
deals with cover
at 80 percent of i will cover 80 percent
of uk trade by
the end of of next year you're making a
serious point about
the the detriment to uh exporters of
some products particularly fishing
products
uh earlier this year and
uh and there are problems continuing i
and i you know i i
i humbly accept that i think that uh uh
it was
in in some ways uh regrettable that uh
some of our uh continental friends and
perhaps make life as easy as they
as they could have done uh we have we
are doing
we are doing what we can we are doing
what we can to redress the matter
uh we've got a 23 million pound fund to
support
uh uh the fishing industry with
with some of the bureaucratic problems
but also uh a hundred million pound
uh fund to enable scottish fishing uh to
to build up in preparation angus in
preparation
for the time when we control uh access
to
every and and the right to fish every
fish in scottish waters
yeah okay back in back to trade we
we know there's no trade deal no new
three deal and the three deals you refer
to our rule
which are the sort of things that are
given no extra gain because we had them
in
in the first place anyway so we've lost
about 4.9
gdp we've gained nothing
so far the best an american trade deal
can give you is that which is
the best one 0.2 so it's equivalent to
losing 4.90 and gaining 20 pence
australia is worth about two pence new
zealand's worth of penny i'm trying to
find out
what do you think cbtp is worth some
people are saying that's not worth very
much either it's worth between
maybe a penny of three pence
well global free trade is something
global free trade is something that is a
great value and
uh we i i uk exports actually rose
last year and i think we're now the uh
the fifth biggest exporter
in the in the world with less than one
percent of the global population
uh that's a that's a stunning
achievement and uh
and it's thanks uh to the uk uh working
together with a great uk
single market uh exporting to the rest
of the world
uh with uninterrupted supply chains and
i think it would be
foolhardy for anybody i can't believe
that you would even think of it
a foolhardy for anybody to detach uh
scotland from the rest of the
of the uk economy and they can break up
our supply chains
in scotland order i think we've run over
your time angus
thank you very much um moving on to
stephen crabb
the welsh selector thank you thank you
good afternoon prime minister
and vaccination program aside why have
so many other parts of the pandemic
response
across the constituent nations of the
united kingdom being fragmented
disjointed and divisive
what went wrong with the four nations
approach stephen i
i'm not sure i'm going to accept the the
premise
um actually there are there are
there are clearly uh competencies that
the devolved administrations
have uh and it's very important that the
messaging should be
uh direct to as direct and as local as
possible
and that's been a been a good thing uh
we've worked together
very closely and if you look at the the
the road map
that we've set out uh it's actually very
similar
uh to uh those that are being followed
around the whole of the uk
and um the you you you rather sort of
um i think you know dismiss
the the vaccination program as they
and as they didn't show the benefits of
the
of the union but plainly it has and it's
been incredible to
go around the country and you know angus
would would concede scottish scientists
in
in livingston or uh scottish uh uh
post-grads in uh in glasgow and
university doing
uh the the the testing uh that we depend
upon to
to isolate the genomic sequence of the
of the bug
throughout the whole of the uk uh
british army people
distributing vaccines across the whole
country it's been amazing it's been an
amazing union effort mr crab
yeah thank you the the point about the
vaccination program it was based
on central government decision making
particularly around
procurement rather than leaving them
leaving into four separate
administrations to make up their own
schemes
and make up their own rules around this
can i ask you prime minister do you
think it was a mistake 12 months ago
not to deploy central civil
contingencies measures to be able to
lead a genuine
uk wide response
there are some people who argue uh that
i think there will be a time will come
where we can we can look back and
and evaluate the uh the way the
messaging worked and
uh the impact of the of the way we uh we
did it and
lots of people and that will be one of
the things i know that we'll be looking
at in the
in the inquiry uh one of the things
we're trying to do now
uh stephen with the with the new uh uk
health security agencies
is not to to take away powers from the
devolved administrations
uh but to make sure that we concert uh
our energies
and uh our thinking more closely
together
thank you prime minister you promised
you've previously spoken about the
good cooperation you felt that's
happened with the devolved
administrations
um the welsh first minister when he was
in front of my committee three weeks ago
um said in contrast that he doesn't
really have a relationship with you he
described it as a remote relationship
he complained that you don't talk to him
so what do you think prime minister
should be the appropriate amount of time
that a uk
prime minister invests in building and
maintaining sustaining relationships
with the first ministers of the devolved
administrations
well i i i'm sorry to hear that the
uh that uh mark draper doesn't feel he
gets enough
uh time with with me uh i will i will do
what i can to
uh to rectify that i've had some i've
had some very good uh meetings and very
good conversations
uh with him uh um
but clearly the the uh the way it works
is
is that the uh the chances of the duchy
of lancaster
uh generally has been sharing the uh the
meetings in
involved and uh that's that's how it has
uh that's hard as how it has
tended to work and it's been it's been
pretty effective and as i said earlier
on
um it's a um
a system that has produced much more
unity uh than is commonly supposed from
the
from the coverage do you think we would
have a stronger union
by a prime minister investing more
direct time themselves with
the first ministers or is it fine just
to devolve
that function almost entirely to the cdl
i i think that the the uh
the role of the prime minister of the uk
is to is is to
is to to lead the whole of the of the uk
and
uh i think i'm very much in favor of
uh of the council of the isles uh for
instance where we come together
uh as a representative across the whole
of
uh the british isles to talk about
issues that matter to uh
to us um on the other hand i don't think
that we want to
turn our deliberations into a kind of
mini eu
if i may say so uh stephen
so just finally and very very quickly uh
prime minister if there was a new first
minister in scotland
after the scottish parliamentary
elections would you
choose to invest more time in a
relationship with them is that something
you would decide to do
well i i you know i i hope i've made my
my
my point about the way i think that this
should
uh this should work i'm the i'm the
prime minister of uh
of scotland as well as of uh
uh the whole of the of the uk and uh
obviously i need a good relationship
with uh with everybody and
i i've talked many times to
uh to nicola to to mark uh
to michelle and arlene and continue to
to do so and that's that's the way it
should be but what i don't think
uh would necessarily be right is to is
to have a sort of
permanent um council as it were
uh you know of the kind that is taking
place tomorrow in
in brussels i don't think that's the
model we're after
great thank you very much as we get to
this the end of this first section about
our place in the world how will the
devolved governments and devolved
parliaments be engaged in the cop 26
preparations
well they they will be
or they're already involved because
uh the cop 26 is taking place in glasgow
and
into indeed i'd just point out to angus
that it's one of the
beauties of the of the union that
the un brings this summit uh to the uk
uh to glasgow
and uh it's thanks to uh
our collective uh membership of the
of the union that we're able to to host
it in in glasgow
and that's a that's a great thing so
there's there's all sorts of
conversations going on
about uh the look and feel of the summit
how it's gonna what is what it's going
to
involve uh the the fringe uh
all that kind of stuff um but we'll move
on to our next section
about covid and we start with jeremy
hunt the chairman of the health
committee
thank you sir good afternoon prime
minister i want to start with the
vaccine issues
in the news today you have been totally
clear
about your opposition to vaccine
nationalism vaccine protectionism
but if british lives were at risk
do you rule out taking measured and
proportionate retaliation
to discourage the eu from impeding
legally binding contracts for our
vaccines
jeremy thank you very much for uh the
the question and you you and
uh you're right to follow this issue as
closely
as you are the uh
part of the the partnership we have with
our uh european
uh colleagues is very very important we
continue to work
uh with them vaccines as you know are
the product of international
cooperation i don't think that
blockades of of either vaccines or
of um medicines of ingredients for
vaccines are
sensible and i think that the long term
damage done by blockades can be
can be very considerable i would just i
would just um
uh gently point out to anybody
considering
a blockade or an interruption of of
supply chains that
uh companies uh may uh look at such
actions and
uh and and draw conclusions about uh
about whether or not it is sensible to
make uh
to make future investments in uh in
countries where
you know uh arbitrary blockades are
imposed
but what's clear is that although you
wish our european friends well you're
not taking anything off the table
in terms of the british response to
decisions this week
our priority is to is to continue the
the vaccine roll out
uh to vaccinate the british people uh
we'll do
uh everything necessary that we can to
ensure that
uh that happens we are on course to
vaccinate uh groups uh one to nine the
jcpi groups one to nine
uh by april the the fifteenth everybody
over
everybody over fifty and every
yeah very bad like it was but very
excited
the cat probably made the symptoms much
less um i want to move on if i may
because one thing that's become very
clear in
the pandemic between the vulnerability
of the social care sector
where as we know 29 000 lives were lost
in
care hopes now we've had 12 white papers
green papers consultations
but you did something different in your
very first speech as prime minister you
said you would
fix the crisis in social care once and
for all
with a clear plan and make sure every
older person was treated with dignity
and respect
do those words still stand they do and
you you'll have heard them many times
jeremy uh you and i since uh there were
we stood on about
58 platforms together uh and and recited
a virtually identical script
uh on on that on that point
so so uh but but the the serious answer
to you
so you go on friends i'm so sorry it's
just the time but sure the reason i ask
it is because last week the nhs got 6.6
billion pounds for covert costs but
there was no mention
of social care in the budget at all and
i just wonder if you can understand the
frustration of
1.6 million people in the sector who
feel they're always treated
as the poor relation and i just one will
you be the first prime minister to say
that social care
will always be treated as equally
important as the nhs
yes and it was one of your achievements
uh jeremy to
turn it into uh the department of health
and social care
and i thought that was the right thing
to do because
there is one of the problems that we
have and don't want to go on about this
for too long
is the gulf between the nhs and social
care
into which uh so many people uh fall and
that's the problem we need to fix
and if you're gonna ask me do we need a
a plan to do it
a long-term plan a 10-year plan then yet
the answer is
is yes and the government will be
bringing forward
our proposals on on social care and
social care
reform later this year fantastic final
question from mr bernard
is social care going to get a mention in
the forthcoming queen's speech
i think it's highly likely but i would
not wish to anticipate
uh the gracious speech at this stage
thank you founders
i'm moving on to meg hilliar chairman of
the pac
thank you chair um prime minister you
say
regrets you've had a few over the last
year which mistake
do you most regret
meg thank you the the um
i think that there are all sorts of
things
uh that i i look back on and i wonder
whether we could have done
uh differently i i wouldn't want to uh
as it were to make a mistake about my
biggest mistake and and single out the
wrong one
uh i think the the uh there are
there are all sorts of all sorts of
things that
as i've said before we didn't initially
understand about covid and
we didn't we didn't get the effect of
the
asymptomatic transmission uh which which
fed into the
the care homes uh epidemic that uh that
jeremy has just been
been talking about uh
you heard patrick and and chris at the
uh the press conference yesterday
talking about some of the things that we
uh we still think about and
and discuss we're learning the whole
time
meg and what what we want is a is a
proper
inquiry as i said earlier on today in
the house uh a proper inquiry
uh in due course when we can consecrate
the time
thank you okay well some of that's
around the science and we
recognize that science has changed but
what about what
lord macpherson described as the most
wasteful and inept public spending
program of
all uh test and trace which you promised
would be world beating
then you promised the moonshot and your
government has committed
37 billion pounds to those were not all
yet spent
are you content with how that's gone
uh actually uh i think the test and
trace
has been an extraordinary achievement
if you said to me um did they get
everything right first time
no uh and and i and that's not
surprising
given what can i complete this because
it's incredibly important
but no one's dropped out i'm not just my
committee that it wrapped up
testing but it's costing
37 billion pounds if it spends through
the money that's been allocated to it
do you think it's value for that money
80 percent of the
of the spending meg goes on literally on
labs on testing on giving people
the results that they so desperately
need and it's not just that individuals
need those those results but it's it's
that massive testing operation
that allows us to know where the disease
is prevalent what type of uh
variant it may be we do half the genomic
sequencing
anywhere in the world it's thanks to nhs
test and trace
that we know whether the disease is
going up and down
in in localities and that gives us the
tools
uh to fight it it's been absolutely
indispensable
one of the tools the clear kills to
fight it is the tracing
prime minister and that's the bit that
died harding herself baroness harding
himself says it's is a challenge to get
people to isolate once you've traced
them
so do you have any regrets about how
you've pulled out that program overall
for the money that you spent on it i
mean i could list many others but i'm
just
focusing on this one now do you have any
regrets do you think it could have been
done better or different there
crucially what do you think you're going
to get for 37 billion pounds
ongoing for the future what's that going
to deliver for the british public
well let me repeat what it what it does
and if you're arguing for spending more
money on uh on the tracing as opposed to
the to the testing
uh then you know we could we can talk
about that but we've uh
we give people uh a uh support
if they needed to isolate councils have
been given
tens of millions of pounds extra to help
people to isolate
about nine million people have been uh
helped to isolate who would who would
otherwise have been in the transmission
chain
and that's a very valuable thing but
what tests and trace really does
is it enables us to know what is
happening with the pandemic in very in a
very granular way
and that is absolutely crucial if you're
going
to fight it okay and given given the
success
do you think that test and trace is
still worth the money you know
as you say you're gonna have a review of
what's gonna be a public inquiry that
will look at all these questions
do you think now we've got the vaccine
program rolling out and projections that
will be rolling out year after year the
37 billion pounds on tests and stress is
still
good value for money i think if you're
asking me should should we have
uh should we have um uh spent
and i think it's so far five billion
pounds up to up to november
uh though you know you're writing the
overall figure that you
that you mentioned for for the whole the
whole budget um
you know should we be spending money on
this scale to
to to isolate where the disease is
prevalent where
where it isn't uh to see what's
happening in younger groups to see
what's happening in older groups
every morning every morning i uh
chair a meeting where i look at the uh
the data
the the dashboard and every week
it has been getting better and better
and more and more detailed and our
understanding
of what we're dealing with has grown and
i think it has been of crucial
importance to us
in uh knowing when the disease is uh is
rising again
uh and what and what we need to do to
deal with so so what you're saying is
it's really been a tool
to map it that's that's what exactly can
i just just check one thing about this
thing
it's been a tool to fight it
in terms of decisions that you've made
do you regret not making a decision
to close down more quickly at christmas
the that decision was made entirely in
the light of what we
uh discovered about the the new variant
and you'll remember
which again was made possible thanks to
the the understanding of what was
happening
uh was made possible thanks to test and
trace and
it was because we were able to see uh
the the b117
variant the so-called kent variant or
english variant uh moving
uh so fast that we were we the
scientists were able to make their
determination
about the uh the increased velocity of
transmission
and so that's why we made it was that
test and trace it wasn't that specialist
scientists who had to track down the
epidemiological trend for that variant i
think that was
it's both both both because you can't do
one without the other
well thank you very last questions about
you do you have any regrets prime
minister about your decision at
christmas which saw where london railway
stations
and others crowded people crowding over
the trains spreading virus
of course of course i regret all the
uh the disruption to people's lives uh
the
the loss of education the uh the the
effects of
of lockdown uh the loss of business uh
the loss of earnings
nobody in my position could conceivably
have
had to take the decisions that i've
taken uh and not regret it of course i
do
but uh you know i i think that christmas
decision
i think that was the i think it was the
i think it was the right thing to do
in the light of the evidence that we had
and if i recall we were given the data
about the speed of transmission
on uh the friday and we made the
announcement on
uh on the saturday i think uh about the
about
what needed to be done and uh yes it was
tough
but it but it but it was i think it was
the right thing to do
can i just say i've taken a close
interest in
the difficulties at tests and trace and
i very much welcome the remarks you make
you made admitting that uh it would have
been better if they had
organized alongside local government and
involved local government
much more intensively earlier so what is
being learned from that
because as prevalence falls the
isolation of the individual cases to
suppress the
virus becomes much more important and
much more
possible because there are far fewer
cases what has been learned from that
period
that is going to be implemented going
forward well i think if you talk to dido
and uh as i'm sure your committee has
and
you listen to the people she's been
working with they she's had
uh local government leaders with her
from the from the beginning and i and i
uh and i've been talking to them as well
uh from the beginning
could we have simply relied on uh local
government
uh uh health officials to to do all the
testing and all the
all the tracing i'm not certain that
that would have been sensible i think
you needed a
combination and i think that's what dido
would argue
thank you we'll move forward to yvette
cooper
the home affairs select committee thank
you
chair and good afternoon prime minister
still on the lessons learnt
issue last march an estimated ten
thousand
separate coveted cases came into the
country mainly from france spain and
italy with no uk
border restrictions in place do you
accept
now that that was a mistake and what
lessons have you learned from it
thanks yvette the the uk has very
tough measures in places as you know
against uh people bringing virus into
this country from france or from uh from
anywhere else
there's a there's a uh so if you come in
in the normal way from
uh from france because you're a british
citizen returning uh from france
for some uh from some lawful activity uh
but you're not on the
uh the special list uh then
uh you uh have to go through a huge
amount to
uh including self-isolation for 10 days
you have to
take a test 72 hours beforehand and
and or two tests uh very considerable
fines if you fail to
to quarantine uh there is a group of
people
who are exempt as you as you say um
uh they uh are overwhelmingly in the
uh they'll be the the people who are
involved in bringing in uh for instance
medicines or
or food to the to the uk
and they typically turn around uh very
rapidly
and and go back uh to france now
uh there is an issue about whether we uh
decide
uh to apply uh more stringent measures
to them uh with the delays that that
would uh entail
and the knock-on effects uh that that
would entail and we're certainly
uh we're certainly looking at that but
people should be in no
under no illusions that they would it
would have consequences
okay that's not an answer to my question
which was about whether you
now felt that last year's failure to put
border restrictions in place
were now a mistake at a time when 130
other countries
um did have restrictions in place and we
didn't but let me turn them to these
current arrangements so france has
two to three new cases of the south
africa and
brazil variants in place so
each day arriving so why have you not
introduced then additional measures or
put france
on the red list yeah we we have got
uh first of all by the way we did
introduce
um bands as as soon as we knew about the
new variants i don't i
wasn't quite sure what you were
referring to uh just now but
as soon as yeah so on december the
december the 23rd measures that we knew
as soon as we knew about um the south
african variant or the
um the brazilian variant uh we
uh we applied uh travel bans on the on
those countries and and
uh and those continue to be in place and
just for everybody's understanding the
uh
this is an issue about trying to keep
out these these variants as
i think your you're driving at at the
moment
uh in the uk uh those variants of
concern
and the you know the uh
the effectiveness of of the vaccines
against them is still a matter of
debate but those variants of concern are
uh are not uh rising their
the numbers are low uh they're
they're stable i think about 350 or so
in the case of
south africa uh maybe uh
50 or so in the case of uh the uh
brazilian
uh and and the monastery much lower so
we're containing those as best we can
with
uh with surge testing and with uh
with door-to-door tracing uh the
which is the i think the right thing to
do and the situation seems to be
in terms of in terms of in terms of
putting putting france on the red list
which is what you're talking about
and uh and with the consequences that
would have
uh for uk uh uh supplies and for
for cross-channel movements uh as
remember 75 of our medicines 50 of our
food come through the
through the short straight so that there
are consequences
but uh it is something that
uh we will have to to look at we will
have to look at
tougher measures just because of this
ambiguity
uh about the effectiveness of the
vaccines
whether you deserve the long answer
you've got 20 000 people arriving
from france in the uk every week of
those
two-thirds are completely exempt from
all of the testing and quarantine
arrangements
everyone understands that hauliers
clearly can't
be covered by quarantine and carry on
doing their vital job but why are you
not
testing them you have two to three
thousand
cases new cases a day of the south
africa and brazil variant
in france and in some parts of france
it's over 30 percent of the cases
and cases have been rising overall so
why are you at least
not testing polios polio's going to
france
are tested you know that system works
why are you not testing julius
coming back into the uk the
number of people coming into the uk
overall from france has
massively diminished there is still
twenty thousand massively but it's it it
was
colossal it's now it's now greatly uh
reduced and the
the numbers of the people who are coming
in are the
um as you rightly say the uh
overwhelmingly uh those whose whose
business is deemed essential for the
security of supply of our of our country
i've explained that tougher measures uh
would have
a very serious disruption on those trade
flows
that has to be balanced against the
current ambiguity
about the effectiveness of the vaccines
on uh
the the variance now uh i
agree with you yvette i agree with you
that this is an issue of
of concern it wasn't until uh quite
recently that the the situation was
the other way around and uh we had a
situation
in uh in france where things seemed more
under control in the uk
we had more of the virus prevalent i
think we now
in all seriousness need to look at the
the situation at the channel uh i'm
afraid that we can't rule out
tougher measures and we will put them in
uh if necessary and
yes uh if it's if it's necessary if it's
necessary
to bring in uh to bring in testing
uh then we will do so but i think you
should understand the
the balance the balance between uh doing
that the disruption
sorry just a second and the and the risk
that we're trying to address
if you give long answers prime minister
it just takes longer yvette's going to
have another question
sorry there's a series of top scientists
and medics have now warned
that the biggest threat to our vaccine
program and to our ability
to come out of lockdown and to keep the
road map
on track is the potential arrival of new
variants particularly from south africa
and brazil now we knew about the rising
numbers of cases
in the middle of february the problem is
this is just one
delay after another every time when i
asked you about brazil last time you
came before the committee
there were then still long delays in
terms of getting there
there were long delays right back at the
beginning you said
just this week previous experience has
taught us that when a wave hits our
friends in europe
i'm afraid it washes up on our shores as
well
but that's because we have no border
restrictions in place
shouldn't that previous experience have
taught us that what we need
is effective border arrangements to stop
cases spreading
prime minister prime minister all right
you need to bring in restrictions and
testing
on julius coming from france thank you
no that isn't actually that isn't true
but thank you for giving me the
opportunity to clarify that
uh yvette there is a balance to be
struck and
what we don't know is the exact state of
the efficacy of the
of the vaccines against the uh the new
variants and we have to balance that
against the very serious disruption that
is entailed by
uh curtailing uh across channel trade
this country depends very largely
uh for the food in our shops for the
medicines that we we need
on that trade flowing smoothly now we
will take a decision
no matter how tough uh to interrupt that
trade
and to interrupt those flows if we think
that it is necessary to protect
public health and to stop new variants
uh coming in and
and it may be that we uh that we have to
do that
uh very soon but i i would ask the
committee just
to think about the logical uh position
when you're when you are in a state of
unknowing about the potential of any
possible variant around the world from
coming into the country
on yvette's logic you would you would
put the whole of the world
into a red list and stop uh movement
uh flowing freely of any kind for a very
long time
and i'm not certain uh that the
uh that is something that the uk economy
the uk public
uh would will understand and accept
because you're doing something
to prohibit movements or stop movements
when you don't actually
know uh the risk that you're trying to
mitigate what we need to see
is a clearer understanding of new
zealand australia you need to see
a clearer understanding and clearer
understanding
of the risk thank you vet prime minister
we finished
because we're going to go on to data now
those those countries with great respect
don't depend on other countries for 75
percent of their
of their medicines and 50 of their food
and and you know i think i hope that's a
point that
we're going to go onto the data now
because you said it's data and updates
um william ragg chairman of the public
administration and constitutional
affairs committee which is responsible
for the government's data
operation
you need to understand bernard and good
afternoon
minister it's good to have you with us
tomorrow you'll
ask for the extension of the coronavirus
act for six
months which goes past the 21st of june
step four of the rip map why
there thank you uh very much well there
are a number of reasons why
uh we want to uh maintain obviously the
the the road map provisions the
restrictions the lockdowns all that ends
so so people shouldn't be confused
between the
the two things uh but what we do need to
do is to continue to be able
uh to deal with the uh the backlogs that
we've
uh we've built up and
to be able to for instance to use
uh remote hearings for for courts to to
clear the backlog in the in the courts
uh to
uh make sure the people who
have returned to the uh the colors in
the nhs
who are volunteering can continue to to
practice and
and to serve uh and uh there are various
powers we need to
to uh to ensure that education can
continue to run
smoothly so those are the reasons why uh
there are
there are powers and and differences
that will persist
beyond the end of the of the roadmap on
june the 21st but
uh be in no doubt that uh after june the
21st all the
uh all the restrictions uh that we have
uh we hope uh will be gone and though
remember that this is a these are these
are
uh not before uh dates there are
there are there that's that's their
status
mr wrap okay thank you for that there's
a number of provisions with
the acts that the government haven't
used so minister can you give
an undertaking that those visions will
be dropped there's no point extending or
so you haven't used
to date uh yes i we we've i think we've
already weeded out quite a few
uh but anything that uh is is redundant
will go
thank you coming on to sage and indeed
other
advisory groups at the weekend a member
of the government's advisory body
set up there wasn't going to be any
international travel this summer that no
doubt cheered the nation
immensely is that the policy of the
government
who sage said that did they sorry
forgive me we'll
a member of a government advisory
committee
okay well uh what we're going to do
is on april the 5th i will get the
findings of the global travel task force
and
i'll be setting out uh where i see uh
what we
what i think it may be possible uh from
may the 17th you know
as yvette was just saying uh things are
looking difficult
uh on the continent and um you know
uh we'll have to uh we'll have to look
at the situation as it develops
but is it helpful to have members of
these august boss sort of freelancing
across the media for
decisions have been made by ministers uh
i i think it's one of those things that
uh i
you know we just have to get used to uh
i think it's been a it's been a feature
of life for quite some time
but do you do you find it held prime
minister
well i think there's a what it shows is
a wide spectrum of scientific opinion
so do advisor buyers and ministers
decide
oh yes very good could i
bring you on to uh committed vaccine um
certificate um do you believe that
the covet vaccine certificate
certification for domestic use
incompatible with a free society
suppliers
i i do think that the basic concept of
vaccine certification uh should not be
totally
alien to us because after all uh when
you have
um uh when you're entrusted with care of
a
patient and uh you say you're you're a
surgeon you're expected to have a
vaccination against
hepatitis b
the principle is is there this is a
particularly
contagious disease it can be very nasty
indeed we've seen what happened in uh in
care homes as we were discussing earlier
it doesn't seem to me to be uh
irresponsible
at all for the uh far from it
it's wholly responsible for um care home
companies to to think of
a requiring vaccination
you mentioned surgeons and and the care
sector that's very different to
the ordinary citizen going to the lab so
is did you recognize abjection for
covert vaccine certification i think
that that's the the kind of thing that
um you know it may be up to individual
republicans uh will um it may be up to
into the landlord
it is i i'm interested to know what
because in politics at the moment it's a
great deal
of time for thought and thinking so i'm
thinking that to perhaps your previous
daily telegraph comes i'm not going to
quote from them don't worry but i'm
wondering if it didn't like please
for those years they're all excellent
and
highly recommended but i cannot function
in in
a past life you writing about being
support of the coveted certificate
vaccine certification to go to the pub
well you know i i you you you'll
appreciate will that uh
uh there are other members of your
committee distinguished members such as
uh such as yvette who take a a
you know passionately opposing view
about
uh the the need for for tougher measures
and
i've i find myself in this uh
long national conversation uh
thinking very very deeply about it and i
think the public have been thinking very
deeply about it
and and my impression is that there is a
huge uh wisdom
in the uh in in the in the public's
feeling about this and people
human beings instinctively recognize
when something is dangerous and nasty to
them
and uh they can see that kovid
is collectively a a threat
and they want us as as their government
and me as the prime minister
to take all the actions i can to protect
them and that's what i've been doing for
the last uh last year or more
a quick final question for me if i may
submit
prime minister have you thought about a
graduated
scheme of sanctions for infractions of
the ministry or cut
do you see the straightforward sound
or resignation of the minister to be too
severe
and have you thought about introducing a
range of them
yes i i actually know uh well i hadn't
thought about a a range of
uh of disciplinary uh measures that one
could take but um
uh i've you know if you if you wanted to
suggest uh
uh you know lesser lesser punishments
um uh then i'd be
perhaps being asked to appear before
this committee
but uh but uh i i i'm happy to think of
i'm happy to think of
uh of uh it's it's an interesting idea
a pleasure and not a chore prime
minister it's a pleasure by the way
that was that was that was i i want to
say what a pleasure it is for me to
appear
in front of this committee and no
punishment so bernard
no pure pure pure unalloyed pleasure at
least on my part
i i recently gave evidence the committee
on silence of public life
about the code and um i will send you my
evidence
would you that would be most kind thank
you but um uh
this idea of having a less absolute uh
binary decision
for a prime minister receiving advice
from the independent adviser it does
seem to me
give the opportunity for the prime
minister to sort things out and rectify
matters
rather than just to get a resignation
and then have the minister back 18
months later
as though nothing had happened which
seems to be a rather unsatisfactory way
of system learning and can we just move
on now to
the economy um there are many other
questions i would love to have asked
myself
um about kevin mel stride
thank you and prime minister good
afternoon welcome to the committee
um prime minister do you think that
these spending assumptions
in the forecast that the obr released
alongside the budget
are realistic uh
the spending assumptions released by the
obr
further i'm sure it's implicit in the
obr's forecast that was
released at the time of the budget are
those figures realistic
just just remind me which particular
figures you have in mind now
the departmental capital expenditure the
the the standard figures that go into
the
fiscal output report with the forecast
that the ovr produces alongside every
major
fiscal event certainly alongside the
budget uh
i i certainly think that the uh the abr
is
uh is right to think that um the
uh the public finances are under very
considerable uh pressure
as a result of of covid and the 400 and
if you if you mean the 407 billion
uh expenditure uh that the
the pandemic is has necessitated then i
i was discussing that last night with
the chancellor and
and certainly agree with that you know
i'm really referring to the forecast
which as you know forecasts out for the
next five years
uh there are are assumptions made as to
what the government is spending in each
one of those
i'm just asking whether yes i think that
that thanks sorry mel on that point i
think what the
uh the abr has been uh suggesting is
that
um i mean obviously there's a
the uh things that things are very tough
and
and spending has been assessed and
necessarily
uh very uh extensive but the
um uh the fiscal repair measures as it
were that uh rishi took in the in the
budget
are set to work over the over the medium
term
well when you say a prime minister that
the obr's figures they are the obl's
figures in the sense that they appear
in the forecast but their figures of
course provided by the treasury
um so i i guess my question is are you
comfortable with the
government's assumptions as to the
spending levels that
uh there are expected to be over the
over
the coming years uh yes because
i'm comfortable with it i wish we
weren't in this uh
in this position i wish we didn't have
to uh to
to fire hose so much money at kobe to
put out the conflagration
uh uh but i think that the chancellor's
budget was extremely good
and uh has put us back on a on a
sustainable path
the reason why i raised this prime
minister is that there are many
economists who believe that the
uh figures that uh on spending within
that forecast are
quite unrealistic and paul johnson for
example at the imfs
uh has offered a ten to one against the
spending assumptions being met and
that's because there are a lot of costs
that one can anticipate coming down the
line that are not captured
within the figures that the treasury
provided uh to the ovr and we've indeed
touched on a number of those areas in
the discussion this afternoon
things of social care commitments for
example that were not
baked into the budget um there's no
explicit uh
provision for spending on annual
vaccinations beyond the current program
we've got test and trace that we've
discussed this afternoon there's huge
backlog
in our hospitals as nurses pay all the
children
who won presumes will need more
resources if they catch up
on lost learning and
perhaps pressure for yet a further
uplift in the uc
and universal credit uplift um doesn't
that
leave you feeling slightly at least
slightly queasy about the assumptions on
spending
that the government's operating to given
its critical importance
in terms of the actions that we take in
supporting the public finances these
these were the figures that the treasury
put out in the the abr
uh recorded uh and i'm you know i'm not
going to make uh
uh predictions now about the future
um uh about future budgets and future
uh spending reviews uh but uh what i can
certainly say is i think that the uk
uh if we continue with the the road map
uh to freedom in the way that we are
uh and as i said uh
yesterday i don't see any reason to any
there's no sign in the data that causes
me
uh to believe we're at this stage that
we're going to have to deviate
uh from that roadmap to freedom i
believe our chances of a strong recovery
are very good
you swear that though saying a little
while ago that you were you remain
committed to resolving the social care
crisis
and yet you know that uh there is no
money
uh in those forecasts to take that into
a chance
those two things it seems to me don't
really square but
if we do accept that
your statement that you do have
confidence in these numbers does that
therefore mean
that taxation as a the total level of uh
the tax burden in the uk would be
expected not to rise
and can you make that commitment uh this
afternoon but we should
expect that what is already uh
that the highest since uh uh jenkins was
chancellor 1960 that we shouldn't expect
the tax burden
uh to rise on the basis of your
confidence in those figures at the
moment
i i well i strongly believe in a low tax
government and i'm a low tax conservator
i think that i think that's the best way
forward for uh for our country and as we
uh as we go forward we're going to want
to be as dynamic and as competitive as
we
as we can possibly be and having a you
know the right physical framework is
uh is is vital for that but the you know
even the the
increasing corporation tax uh is
is is doesn't come in for two years uh
and um it's it's the the rate is at the
still at the lowest in the uh in the g7
and uh it's preceded by
a super deduction uh for capital
investment for business investment which
i think is incredibly
attractive and i hope will give people
confidence and
get to get our economy moving and and i
don't think you should
necessarily draw the conclusion from
what's in the abr
numbers about spending that we won't
have the uh the room to
uh to make the profound changes on
social care that jeremy and i discussed
earlier on
do you think very briefly required
required uh it would not require any uh
uplift in those numbers spent because
they're not captured in there at the
moment and that's quite a
large bill but can i just ask one final
question you mentioned very brief
production
the super deduction lasts for two years
we know
thereafter companies that currently have
chronically low levels of
uh investment not just because of the
pandemic because we've had a
historical uh situation there will then
go into a situation where that support's
not there and
corporation tax is rising quite
significantly
what is it after the super deduction has
gone through uh in that couple of years
that will be there from the government
support
corporates investing government well
you've got a you've got a world now in
which uh
business rates uh uh are unprecedentedly
uh low vats been uh being cut
you've got uh as you know mel because
you know you've been following this
uh throughout huge uh support through uh
sea bills through uh through furlough
through all the
the instruments the government has has
used uh
plus you've now got a um a super
deduction for
for investment and to say nothing of the
the kickstart
uh funding for for hiring people um
a huge package to get the economy moving
and
the the purpose is to trigger uh
confidence growth and
uh and investment and a virtuous circle
prime minister thank you thank you thank
you merriman
the chair of the transport committee
we can't hear you mermaid you you need
to unmute
hello
can we back come back to you hugh we'll
we'll
can we sort out his sound
he's he's but by the looks of him he's
in port culley's house
uh we'll come back to you he's just down
the road he could walk it he could
literally walk in here but i mean we can
do this incredible thing
you know called uh called uh you know
called actual propinquity
and why don't we have a revolutionary
concept in a covered secure way
you could come and sit yes i agree with
that here if you want to just abandon
your
workstation and come down here we'll
sort it out that way should we
move that's cool temporarily to julian
knight now then please
hope we can hear you again thank you
sure it would take me a lot longer to
walk from starly hall to
oculus house um the digital culture
and sports sectors is no doubt you're
aware prime minister worth nearly a
quarter
of the uk economy yet post-brexit
people in these sectors are being asked
to pay an economic
visa piece just to work overseas in the
eu
can't and they can't transport their
instruments all their gear
and they're all already being overlooked
for work in favor for those who have
eu passports why were these sectors
allowed to suffer what is effect
a no deal brexit julian uh first of all
i want to i want to say how
strongly i share the your frustration
and the frustration
of that sector can you hear me
can you hear me i i i totally share that
i totally share the frustration of the
sector this is a massively important
uh part of our economy uh contributes
many many tens of billions of pounds in
in in tax revenue
uh in employment and to the general joy
of the
and productivity of the of the nation
there's no it's it's
it is hugely important and we and
they're also
a massive export industry so uh we we
must fix this and
the the answer is i'm afraid that in the
course of the negotiations the
the eu as a whole uh did not uh give us
the deal that uh
we wanted on this uh on this issue uh
though of course we have absolutely
we're not placing any restrictions on
people coming to the to the uk we're
very happy to welcome
uh performers uh uh from around the
world that always be part of our
of our global britain approach um but
what we've got to do now in the the time
we do have some time because
obviously given what we've been
discussing earlier
uh the um uh
there are there isn't a great uh hubbard
of of traveling
uh musicians and theater companies and
and so on uh around and doing gigs
around
uh around the rest of europe uh that's
been put on hold for a while
but what we were working flat out
with um bilaterally with each individual
government and some of them are much
much better i'm sure you know julie
because you know a lot about this
some of them are much much better and
forward-leaning than others some of them
it's been absolutely fine
uh others were still we've still got
progress to make but
um one of the reasons that uh uh i i've
invited nick heitner
to help us in this whole sector is
is so that we can we can get ready for a
proper uh
return to our cultural life uh in the
autumn
uh in the way that i think every every
everybody would want
thank you thank you thank you for those
encouraging words what the dcms
sectors would like to hear from you is
that it's a pledge to get this sorted
we're already a quarter of the way
through the year and as such there's no
bilateral talks that have taken place
where will those talks take place and
who will lead them on our side
well they're there the the initiative
actually the there are plenty of
conversations already happening between
at uh
a national capital levels between uh the
uk
and uh our partners uh david frost
uh lord frost is an overall charge of uh
of making this happen
one of the things that we're we're
looking at doing is
is uh uh you know we're using we've got
1.57 billion as you know that we put
into uh the
sector to support it in all sorts of
ways and we want to be uh helping
uh in the meantime with with some of
that funding
thank you prime minister i'm glad you
mentioned paul frost because he's
declined
two invitations now to appear before my
committee so perhaps you could have a
gentle word
i i will understand as i understand it
is that there has a mission who will be
undertaking the first stage of the
bilateral talks
that i think will take too long will you
consider short-circuiting this
again our ministers negotiating with
this from spain
italy and greece which seem to be the
most recalcitrant nations in terms of
visa access
yes uh look i'm i'm passionate about
this
uh i think it was in 1620 that the
group called the english comedians
performed hamlet in
uh in german as far as i remember uh you
know this is
this is this is something that has been
going on for hundreds and uh
hundreds of years uh we we must get it
properly ironed out it's a it's an
obvious uh
uh it's a two-way street uh we need to
we need to
to make sure that uh we get this this
thing totally sorted out and
and our cultural life can our greatest
cultural exports
uh can continue to flourish thank you
one final question
chair if i may uh so it's changed in
terms of code insurance and festivals
every year there are 975 festivals in
the uk from drust debris of course
to the asparagus fair institute but
without limited government-backed covert
cancellation insurance
we risk throwing away economic
advantages
from our brilliant vaccine program prime
minister will you back a covered secure
summer of fun
rather than condemning us to a summer of
none
uh that well that i i mentioned the the
work that uh nick
uh heightener is is is leading
for us uh we're looking at ways
that we can make this happen uh uh
uh oliver dowden uh the uh the cultural
secretary cms secretaries
is clearly leading on this he's done a
huge amount of work and uh trying to get
the sector
ready i think one thing that i don't
want to
see is people
unwilling to take risks on
productions on performances on events
because uh
there were you know they think about
what happened last year when
uh as we've discussed uh we thought we
could get things open
uh and then sadly because of the way the
pandemic went
uh we couldn't move forward and we
remember we had a huge effort on
on lateral flow testing uh to try and
move things things forward
uh to get something ready for the autumn
or for the or for the christmas season
even now you have to
uh do the rehearsals you have to do to
get the scenery all that stuff it takes
a huge amount of time
preparation and expense and we i totally
get that
and uh so that's why we're looking at
what we can do to top slice some of the
1.57
uh billion uh to see if we can be useful
uh in that way i mean the the the there
is a
uh there are difficulties with this
whole business of indemnifying
uh the entire sector as i'm sure you'll
uh appreciate
and i'm sure mel uh would appreciate but
that's what we're looking at can i
i i wouldn't suggest one time i would
suggest identifying the whole sector but
a date in time
limited only to the costs incurred i
think there is a way forward with this
prime minister
at the moment i have to say it's not
being we're not being listened to
we have really serious proposals on this
so hopefully you will
take that back okay i'd love to love you
love to yeah i think that was a point
and not a question but may i
um as a vice chairman of the all party
music group just reinforce
a very strong feeling in the music of
performing arts
that we have been slow on the uptake of
the seriousness
of the impact of brexit on touring
musicians and performers
and that we've it has looked as though
we've not been prepared to listen i've
asked oliver dowden the secretary of
state to host a zoom call of people
actually who are practitioners on the
front line can i
invoke your support for this initiative
of listening and gathering intelligence
yes
and and and so bernard i i what i can
think of nothing violent to make sure
that you can lead a
a choir of brexiteers thank you uh
but also can i add portugal to the list
and it is
it is very much um uh
many of the issues are very much
confined to certain countries of concern
and it's not due to any malevolence of
those countries
it is the bedding down of new procedures
and practices
which are unfamiliar to the officials in
those countries so can i
ask you to not only advise lord frost to
attend the dcms select committee to
address these matters but also
that there should be a foreign office
minister yes
who is going to take the fight to the
through the embassies
into campaigns in the individual
countries but it needs to be addressed
country by country otherwise we will
make very very slow progress
it does this is one of those
opportunities for strong bilateral
engagement
thank you very much prime minister for
those assurances and we'll now go to
uh hugh merriman who's been allowed to
join us in person
uh for his questions about transport
well chairman thank you
prime minister thank you for unlocking
me and inviting me down to the room
technology broke down um i want to ask
about international travel
yes uh you've said uh to this committee
and indeed yesterday to the public that
on the fifth
of april you will have more to say is
the 5th of april the day
when the global travel task force
framework
will be known to the public that's right
and with that regard are we likely to
see a framework that just sets out the
criteria
um or will it be known which country
goes into which criteria by
the fifth of april i think uh hugh with
great respect you'll probably have to
wait till the fifth of april to
see the see the details uh the hope is
that we can we can get uh people uh
moving again
by uh by may the 17th by step three in
the way that uh
i i've set out on the road map um
we'll just have to see where we get to
and where other countries get to and
uh and what the what the data is telling
us okay but it's great news because it's
a week earlier than we thought the
task force would publish so can i
perhaps push you does that mean there
might be
a week earlier where people can be able
to start flying
and traveling again uh where's we're
sticking to the to the red map
okay so i can't give you i can't push
you uh earlier than the suburbs
the reason for that i mean i just said
i'm not sure the committee knows it's
backwards but the the reason for that is
is
the simple epidemiological reason that
a five-week interval uh is a sensible
one
uh it's uh it gives you a chance to
assess the
impact of the previous changes it'll be
five weeks on
since the april uh the twelfth uh
opening of non-essential retail
uh we need to couple with the impact of
the
uh of schools and everything else and
we'll need to see uh what that's done
okay i understand and actually it's
great news that we're here a week
earlier in terms of that news
can i perhaps ask you where we are in
terms of discussions with
other international leaders because
obviously for every plane that leaves
the uk it will need to land in another
country have for example you had
conversations with president biden
as to our ability to restart uk
us flying again at the time we're ready
to be able to fly
we're discussing the whole time with and
i know that grant is discussing the
whole time the
sexual transport secretary with uh
colleagues around the world when
uh we can get things moving but we'll be
all
all of us are looking at the pandemic
and and
uh and when it's sensible to do so and
in terms of
prioritizing those conversations asking
you to
to give information are you looking at
the countries that are ahead of the game
as we are with vaccination rollout so
again the us is a country that seems to
march forward
in the way that the uk has in terms of
those conversations so that we have
some form of agreed standard on
traveling you said before that
vaccination
certificates or passports may be an
inevitability so have we had those
conversations about what
uh the framework would be in terms of
rules i i don't think that there's been
a
a an international as it were concord at
on
uh vaccination passports but there's no
doubt that there's a there's a
growing global uh consensus uh that for
the purposes of
uh of aviation and that uh evidence of
vaccination
uh or uh immunity
uh that you've had the the disease all
that
you've taken a negative test uh all of
these will be valuable
and do you regard the vaccination
certification as a commercial necessity
the one that government wouldn't stand
in the way of if that was the way to
unlock people's ability to fly again
yeah i i think i'm
i'm on the you know i think that there
are obviously uh
you can either um there's a hierarchy
between sort of
mandating something and permitting it
and or
or forbidding it um and uh
you know i think that in some areas as
we were talking about earlier on
uh particular sectors were vulnerable uh
elderly people are being cared for
you know there may be some need for
mandation some
some need for a more permissive approach
all that will be set out in due course
okay and perhaps can i also ask you
it may well be the case due to what's
going on in europe and elsewhere that
there are certain parts of the
transportation
system that can't operate as other parts
of the economy can by the 22nd of june
would you be willing to look again if
there are government imposed barriers
to travel domestically and
internationally at a sector-based
uh compensation scheme uh to ensure that
those
organizations can stay in business if
they can't do business
you mean like aviation aviation good
example but we also have the coaches
uh sector actually in this room this
morning and they've been particularly
impacted as well
um well aviation we've supported i think
with about seven billion pounds
already we're going to continue to have
issues
uh that we'll have to deal with in uh in
the aviation sector
for a long time to come uh coach
industry
uh we're supporting all sorts of ways
not least in uh buying
uh loads of green uh loads of green
buses so perhaps they're
uh they're not so so useful in the
actual uh coach sector
uh but um the best thing for all those
sectors is to get us
all moving again and and that depends on
the rollout of the vaccine and defeating
the virus
thank you and one last question if i may
chat it always seems to be the case now
that the use of going abroad
on holiday is a dirty word uh which is
absolute tragedy given and you yourself
are a great internationalist
and that we've always ruled the waves in
terms of our exploring abroad
how do we get this market opened up
again and how do we also get people to
look beyond
these shores i think you do not
underestimate the
natural uh wanderlust
of spirit of inquiry general dynamism of
the
the british people that has served us uh
for hundreds and hundreds of years and
as soon as people feel it is safe
uh they you will see a miraculous change
in
uh the mood and and what happens that's
that's what
this is all about uh and we're getting
there uh as i say step by step
jab by jab we're not there yet but i'll
be saying more
on uh on april the 5th and uh and then
on the 12th and
um we will we will do what we can and
you just unlocked me from my room so i
could come down here
uh are you managing to unlock yourself
uh and give yourself a foreign holiday
uh over summer as well as supporting of
course the domestic all right
i think i think i will be whatever
i do i will be making sure to and tell
the the british
public uh what i think is safe and uh
and sensible i certainly won't be doing
anything
anything other than that thank you thank
you
thank you um we're going to if you can
indulge us and i'm sorry
just another ten minutes would do sure
which is that
um the chair of the procedure committee
uh karen bradley would like to ask about
um lifting copied restrictions in
parliament to restore the effectiveness
thank you very much sir bernard and
prime minister we've just seen
a real example of the hybrid parliament
working where
we've had to have a physical uh
participation from mr merriman rather
than
virtual but one thing that we can say
about
westminster is that the house of commons
has been able to operate and and has sat
throughout the whole of the pandemic
unlike many other
national parliaments around the world
and that's thanks to
the innovation of the digital team and
the house staff
for being able to make this happen um
but of course compromises
have been required mr i'm just curious
what is your view
of how parliament has operated in this
last 12 months well i i think it's been
uh heroic actually and i think that the
staff and
of the house commons have done an
absolutely unbelievable job and don't
forget
that many of them can work in
professions that
we would i think looking at the the way
the epidemic was think it was quite high
risk because
uh they had to come into regular contact
with uh large numbers of different
people
uh in in close proximity
uh when we've seen the effects on uh
some professions of the of the disease
uh and so i thank them very very much
for what they've done
they've uh they've kept going i think
what the public my broad
my broad instinct is that the public
would like us as parliamentarians to be
uh returning uh to uh life pretty much
as
as normal uh parry pass you
at the same pace as uh as everybody else
and i think
that's what we should go for can i join
you in
thanking the staff of the commons and i
think you know we we know we've lost
some very special members of staff
over the last 12 months and we should
all remember that and the the work that
they do
but you've talked about staying in step
with the road map out of lockdown for
parliament
some some colleagues would like to go
faster some colleagues think
that the house of commons should show
leadership and that perhaps things like
social distancing shouldn't apply in the
house of commons chamber
when it does apply to the rest of the
country what's your view
my instinct is that is the one i just i
just mentioned
uh karen i i would be inclined uh to
support an approach that is
uh that is you know adopted everywhere
the the house of commons should be
uh like any other uh part of the uk we
should we should go
uh we should we should be uh you know
meeting and mingling when it's
when it's safe to to do so when the
science says that's
that's okay thank you if i could bring
us on to
when we are back to some form of
normality um
the attrition rate for female mps
serving in the house of commons is far
worse than male mps
we've got some figures from the house of
commons library that indicate
that women mps serve on average one
parliamentary term less than their male
counterpart now there may be very
many reasons for that but one of them
might well be
down to the procedures of the house of
commons i wonder based on our
experiences
over the last 12 months and and some of
the things that we've done
over the last 12 months and also your
experiences of parliamentarian are there
any procedural changes you would like to
see
that we could uh look at that might mean
that women
were able to uh make a successful career
in parliament more women were able to
make a successful
career in parliament uh i do actually
think that there are
that we need to harvest the the best
things uh you know the this has been a
terrible pandemic it's been an appalling
year but we have learned to do some
things quite well
and i think that technology has been
i've definitely been our friend
uh and you know this isn't this is
something that the
the government doesn't uh dictate at all
this is for the commons it's
for uh for mps for the speaker to
to work out how to do it but uh whether
there are improvements that can be made
uh the particularly family-friendly
improvements uh then i i'd be i'd be on
for that
um i think the the way the commons works
has improved quite a lot
uh even in my time uh here
and um and that's been to the to the
good it's me it's a bit i think it has
helped
uh us get more female mps but we've got
to realize
there are still very considerable
barriers and the the the
you know some of the uh the deterrent
that female mps faces is absolutely
appalling i mean
you know we've discussed the the online
uh trolling the the the abuse
uh anything we can do to make things
easier more family friendly seems to me
to be
something that would be sensible for uh
the speaker
is his team to look at and all the any
particular innovations you would like to
see perhaps continue that we've tried
through the
course of the pandemic i'm thinking
about the way we're voting maybe some
virtual participation
i i wouldn't want to commit to to
to any particular change uh karen i just
think that generally we there we should
be looking with the speaker
and the commons together should be
looking seriously at the
the general you know benefits of of
remote
uh uh debate the ways we've been able to
do things
uh differently i think sometimes it's
it's worked sometimes it's been
less successful um and i've no doubt at
all
uh speaking entirely personally the
people i want the chamber to be full
again
i i i want the uh people to have a sense
that
uh they can they can see the the the
sentiment
uh expressed in the in the room
understand where the debate is going
uh by the the by the this you know the
sea anemone
movement of the of the of of the
benches and see and see how the argument
is is working and hear the
the acclaim or the abuse i think that's
that's that's that's very very
uh important and we need to we need to
learn from we need to learn directly
from each other
um i think that probably um it's a good
idea
for colleagues to uh
be able to mingle uh again
in the lobbies and so i would be
inclined
to i know it's incredibly old-fashioned
and
uh but insofar as as we possibly can
i think that voting uh as a as a as a
communal act
uh together uh has immense benefits
because
you you you know you re you know it's
not just pressing a button uh you really
have to
uh to commit uh do you have to think
about it yet
prepared to justify what you're doing uh
to your to your friends to your
colleagues to your to your whips
uh as you go around the the uh
these ancient buildings so uh i've you
know
i hope i don't sound uh like a a crazed
traditionalist when i say
i see a merit in that but there are
there will be things that
uh we can do differently and better and
i wouldn't what i really wouldn't want
to
uh to you know be too prescriptive about
that i think a lot of people will
spend a lot of time looking at what's
worked and what hasn't worked and
i'd encourage them to to harvest the
best
just one final point you've said prime
minister that this is a matter for the
house but obviously
it's the government that has to provide
time for debates on these matters and
for the house to then be able to make a
decision
can you commit to giving some time for
that debate i'm sure that that will
that's going to be a a necessity we're
going to have to
to look at ways of improving uh our
proceedings making them more family
friendly i have no doubt about that
thank you well prime minister um as
as my personal viewer as someone who's
also committed to a 50 50 parliament i
very much welcome
your open mind on these matters can i
just press you in particular on the
on the proxy voting issue which has
been a great help to people who have
caring responsibilities who are
of course mostly women and so if we went
back to the pre-covered
situation we are in fact we would in
fact be reinvoking
um an indirectly discriminatory regime
um so i hope i perhaps you could just
confirm
that you have an open mind on that
question as to whether um additional
proxy votes could be available for
people with caring
i certainly think we need to be looking
at measures that are that are family
friendly and i mean i
i've said what i've said about the the
value of the
um of voting together but i'm sure that
all mps uh get that point but you know
the
appointment you make is also a very good
one like you i'm a traditionalist and
the last thing i want is ministers to
have proxy votes so they never see
the rest of the world exactly that's
very important
can i just also very briefly return to
the cop 26
yes question which is
one of the top priorities of the
government in this in this calendar year
um and we've arranged for alok sharma
the
president's designated to appear before
different the different select
committees that have an interest in this
um and
but the concern that we have is that
this doesn't yet look like this same
consuming priority of for this
government
as other policies what can you do to
ensure that all the government
departments are engaged
all efforts are being made to secure the
agreement of 190 countries
and it engages domestic policy as well
well thank you very much and you i
unless i specifically tell you otherwise
i want you to know that
i'm engaged in some kind of cop uh
conversation
uh virtually every day and there are and
that probably goes for every other
uh secretary of state or certainly uh in
many departments that there will be
ministers who spend
uh a lot of time every week now thinking
about
uh issues to do with uh uh
howard our green industrial revolution
uh the ten point plan
um uh attaching climate change and and
the cop summit
so it's a it's a big big
cross-governmental effort
it's being led by by a lock but it's
it's certainly
something that we're we're gripping
across whitehall you chair the climate
action
strategy cabinet committee how often
should it be meeting
yeah that is one forum uh i
it hasn't uh to be frank met a great
deal because we've been doing a lot of
ad hoc meetings and that's how it's
uh it's been working i mean i've been
meeting colleagues uh pretty
continuously over the
over the last uh few months and it will
intensify because
uh the question now really is just to
make sure
that we can have a a cop that is
um that is physical and to get back to
the
the question that karen was was talking
about i i really think it'd be
a wonderful thing if by november uh the
uk
can lead the world in all sorts of
things but actually have a a
a summit that is a big global summit
uh where everybody turns up and
everybody turns up without fear
prime minister thank you very much
you've given us a great deal of time
thank you we've covered a lot of ground
we're looking forward to seeing you
towards the end of the summer and then
again in the autumn
and i'm very grateful for the time you
give this committee
it's a great help to the work of the
select committees
order order thank you sir thank you
the proceeding has ended
the proceeding has ended
the proceeding has ended
the proceeding has ended